so the Multiverse is dying
yep things aren't looking good and
everything's Fade to end in a multitude
of incursions and multiversal wars that
ultimately destroy timelines across the
Marvel Universe after first being opened
up during the events of Lucky season 1
we've slowly seen projects embracing it
from across the pantheon of Marvel
movies and shows so far it's been
explored and what if Venom let that be
Carnage no way home morbius Multiverse
of Madness and across the spider-verse
I've recently been rereading Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers run and this seminal
Arc pulls together a wealth of things at
all culminate in secret Wars that 2015
book has a lot going on with it and with
that being well we're eventually headed
I think we have to get used to what it
means now in order to explain this we
have to look at what we're told in
across the spider-verse this spans of
Marvel Multiverse with Miles Morales
meeting several different spider people
in it we discover that Miguel O'Hara was
desperate for a family and that he
traveled to Universe where a version of
him and had one and had died this in
ended up destroying said universe and
since any stoneware every account within
his power to stop non-canon events from
destroying others this is why he doesn't
want Gwen meeting miles why Jefferson
has to die and why people that don't hit
subscribe could risk losing it all now
this is a similar thing to what Doctor
Strange touched upon during Multiverse
of Madness though he met a Christine
variant he couldn't be with her because
of incursions causing the universes to
start to come together and that takes us
into the first big part of the video
which is explaining how that all works
what happened with it in the comics and
also how the heroes managed to find a
way to stop incursions from destroying
the 616 as you mentioned all of this
started during Jonathan Hickman's
seminal Avengers run which also carried
over into his new Avengers stuff in one
book you had the public facing stuff
that the Avengers were doing and this
involved things like invest to getting
why they were a group of Godlike
creatures called the gardeners that had
entered the Universe on the other side
of this he had the secret society of the
Illuminati in the New Avengers which
only a select few were actually aware of
they were working a way to keep things
quiet investigating incursions and
destroying any earth that could come
into contact with the 616. this ran from
Avengers world through to the infinity
storyline before going into time runs
out and then finally Secret Wars
ultimately it ended up streamlining all
the universes so we had Miles Morales
coming into the main one along with all
the other big characters that were in
offshoot books on different worlds we
will of course have you covered
throughout this video but I definitely
recommend picking up Hickman's run if
you love this movie as much as I did I
think the best thing to talk about next
is what an incursion actually is in the
comics as it's slightly different to how
they operate in the MCU however they do
have some similarities and just like you
saw in Multiverse of Madness Two Earths
start to merge into one they take eight
hours to collide with each other and
both the Earth and their respective
universes are destroyed in this
Collision during 2013's New Avengers
issue 1 black panther saw the stud of
this and encountered Black Swan who was
from a colliding Earth they ended up
imprisoning her and she became a big
part in this and the superior Iron Man's
story now what's important about in mind
that incursions can only be witnessed if
you step behind an invisible barrier
that shows you the incoming Collision
sort of acts like a doorway and to
everyone on the other side of this they
can't see what's going on whereas once
you pass through you can pursue the
incoming Earth now the only way to
seemingly stop this incoming Earth is to
destroy it and it's very much a survival
of the fittest mentality that saves
their world but completely Dooms another
we'll talk about how the Illuminati
operated during this but with black
panther being a member and and the whole
invisible wall thing the incursions
didn't get out for quite some time
either way the Illuminati were working
away secretly to get to the root cause
of them whilst also destroying worlds to
save the 616. once it's all got out an
original sin it caused a hell of a lot
of issues because the Illuminati were
murdering billions on mass every time
they destroy the world however they were
doing it to save their own so you you
could kind of see things from their
perspective though it's a very morally
gray area now the root cause of the
incursions was due to one of the Earth's
in the Multiverse exploding 25 years
before it was supposed to this caused
what's known as a contraction in the
multiversal timeline that rippled out
and knocked the other Earths out of
whacked which caused the domino effect
it's also important to bear in mind that
the Universe has beings in them known as
Builders who created everything at the
dawn of time they built worlds and sent
in beings known as gardeners that would
evolve life on the planet and then
continue from there and if life worked
then they would move on to another world
but if the life was bad then they'd go
and destroy it the opening of Avengers
World centered around this with a team
going against a gardener called ex
nahilo now this provided a good
distraction for some of the characters
and it allowed the Illuminati to deal
with the incursions whilst everyone
looked the other way now the incursing
Earth usually appeared red but beings
known as the map makers turned some blue
and this was so they could track them
this also allowed them to identify those
who were interfering with the will of
the universe and get to the true reason
behind all the incursions now it turns
out that the person who set them off was
actually Dr Doom and this was because he
was trying to stop the plan of the
beyonders yes Doom was actually trying
to save the entire Multiverse but
instead he ended up destroying it he's
made you look a right knob now the
beyondes exist in a space beyond the
Multiverse and in Doom going against
them it set off this chain of events
just like all omnipotent beings in the
media the beyonders saw humans as their
play things and while they were meant to
be stewards of the Multiverse from the
outside they had their own nefarious
plans they wanted to conduct an
experiment of destroying the entire
Multiverse set and this was so that they
could see what happens it's kind of like
when you drop a Mentos and a Diet Coke
or make a potato clock you just kind of
messing around but John tickle from
Brainiac he would never do this
anyway we're here for the science aren't
we we're here to find out which floats
best an au pair or a fake pair
what now their overall plan was to use a
bomb in each Universe to destroy each of
the Worlds at the same time this bomb
would be a person and they placed it in
the Universal constant Owen Reese aka
the molecule man he first appeared in
fantastic for 20 way back in 1963 and
gained his powers from the Beyond air
after an atomic incident seemed like it
was all just one big kerfuffle you know
he got himself in a pickle but in
another plot twist we learned his origin
was actually planned this was carried
out by the beyondes so his origin was
constant across the Multiverse and thus
they had a way to control and manipulate
every reality a Doom installed by
molecule man that in order to save the
universe he'd need to kill every single
version of him across the entire
Multiverse this would stop the Beyond
his Twisted science experiments and the
bomb that molecule man was wouldn't end
up detonating a molecule man set this
off by killing evasion of himself 25
years ago but this created the death of
the universe that then caused the
contractions this had a dormant effect
until seven years after that which is
when the incursion started and the
Beyond us then noticed this three years
after infecting the AI that traveled
across the universe is they then used
that as a way to track the depths of
molecule man happening across the
Multiverse this would then be used to
help them find Dr Doom and his army of
swans which were being used to kill all
the molecule men this caused a secret
war in which the beyonders were battling
Doom to exact their plans on the
Multiverse whilst he was attempting to
stop them now the big weakness at the
beyonders had was that they couldn't
travel back in time and this was due to
them being stuck having to live in
linear time Doom uses to defeat them and
in taking their power where he then
created the battle world now that's kind
of what happened in the comics but
depending on what goes with Kang and
also Jonathan Majors We Are Gonna See
How They adapt that I am kind of
skipping ahead there and just telling
the big overarching story so you get the
context but for the next part of the
video I want to go into what happened
with the Illuminati and then how this is
echoed in across the spider-verse but
let's not get to ahead of ourselves as
all of Doom's plans existed without
anyone knowing now the Illuminati needed
a way to deal with arguably the biggest
threat they'd ever faced and this led
them to do ax hitherto and dreamed of
did you seriously just say hitherto and
dreamed of well we look at what they'd
face before you know they can fight a
Thanos they can fight a Galactus that
they can do a Time Heist you know they
can they can hit a thumbs up button
however when it comes to things like
this it's kind of Beyond them destroying
an entire world in order to save their
owners something that very few are
equipped to deal with unless they had to
become like Oppenheimer in order to
carry it out
the destroyer of worlds now during the
events of Avengers vs X-Men Captain
America discovered the Illuminati and he
was Furious to learn about Tony's secret
dealings these were people who'd had
their hands in almost everything since
their formation and the fact that even
the Avengers didn't know about it was a
really really sore Point first to bury
the hatchet Tony invited him into the
group but pretty early on he realized he
wasn't the right person for the job the
Illuminati are extremely Cut Throat
because they have to make tough choices
and people like Steve aren't exactly the
best fit now the Illuminati feel like
they're the most equipped to do this
because they have someone in them that
represents every aspect of Earth for
example you have Tony representing the
humans Doctor Strange representing magic
name all for Atlantis blackball for the
Inhumans Professor X represented the
mutants and black panther the wakandans
each one of them would meet in secret
when a large threat was on the horizon
and they'd then decide how best to
handle it now Steve like I said he isn't
exactly a cut and run kind of guy and
whereas the rest wanted to destroy the
uncursing Earth he refused used to do it
at his course Steve's biggest flaws that
he refuses to make sacrifices then he'll
do whatever he can to come to a
resolution where nobody has to die this
most notably caused them to take the L
in Infinity War but it's very much the
character's greatest strength and his
greatest weakness now why I'm telling
you this is because he refused to do
anything that would destroy another
Earth and instead he came up with the
idea of using a newly built Infinity
Gauntlet this would be so they could
push the other Earth away go to the
Winchester and wait for it all to blow
over however this didn't work and it was
worse for Steve than when he got to meet
his and he's Shannon for the first time
in that alternate timeline better not
tell Peggy about Civil War I'm trying to
stop this shattered all the Infinity
Stones except for the time Jam which
then traveled into the future it
disappeared out of sight unless the
Avengers were left there looking like
mugs I think in the MCU we're gonna get
a similar sort of thing as the Infinity
Stones have now been destroyed and thus
they can't be used in the main Earth to
help divert incursions now obviously
with the plan to push thing things
causing the destruction of the stones
they didn't really want to attempt
anything else that could cause even more
damage So the plan was just to destroy
the incoming Earth instead then go to
the Winchester have a pint and wait for
all to blow over Captain America wasn't
really that pleased though so what the
Illuminati did is that they wiped his
memory yep everything he learned about
the Illuminati that's no more and he
can't remember there's a big thing going
on right now that he can only stop by
destroying another Earth Hickman played
with this brilliantly and at the start
of Avengers world we watch as Steve woke
up which is where he told Tony that he'd
had a bad dream we got a flash of the
Illuminati standing around him but
beyond that he couldn't quite grasp what
had actually happened again you had
these two stories going on with the
Avengers Comics just showing that
everyone was up to their old ways and
fighting the good old fight however in
the New Avengers the Illuminati was
dealing with the untold cost of stopping
all the incursions if you register
initial Avengers run I think you'd think
things were pretty cliche as they just
sent Steve about to do simpler things
like recruit other Avengers and fight
big battles in space because he was
distracted the Illuminati were now free
to head out and deal with the incursions
uncumbered by the Boy Scout now there's
lots of big stories that happen in this
and there's a time where they've had a
world that has a play on the Justice
League and both teams initially want to
find a peaceful resolution as time goes
on though and that clock starts to take
down they just say it and have a
fight there's also an instance where
Neymar stormed out because they wanted
to try and find a way to avoid
destroying the other Earth the eight
hours counted down and then they hit
zero minus one second minus two seconds
minus three and the countdown just kept
going past that everyone's confused
thinking you know we should all be dead
now and they started to question whether
they'd gotten a false positive it made
them think their instruments might be
wrong or maybe they'd got the entire
incursion things wrong right from the
start what had actually happened though
is that Nemo had gone off recruited a
bunch of supervillains and they'd got
together and destroyed the the entire
Earth yeah very messed up and as we
touched on Steve's memory was fixed in
the original sin run which made him
remember everything exposing the secrets
he then confronted Tony directly and at
this point he just lost it and beat the
crap out of him now there was just one
problem with this and something you need
to bear in mind when you fight Tony
Stark don't yeah don't whatever you do
or fight him in his home this is what
Tony makes clear too and when you're in
his office you're in his Workshop his
War Room the one place you don't want to
be if you're his enemy launching all his
Iron Man suits he then even the odds and
it was such a cool moment that just made
my jaw hit the floor when I read it now
eventually things led into Secret Wars
but we can easily see how the Illuminati
here are being brought across to the MCU
version the illumawati in Multiverse of
Madness we finally saw them in the 838
and this happened after we got a teaser
nine man 2. in that film he could catch
a glimpse of Tony Stark's phone with an
Illuminati app on it so pretend actually
the team was formed then and even the
audience didn't know about it either way
the 838's Illuminati explained the
incursions in the MCU and we know that
these operate slightly differently
however where the Illuminati is similar
is that they've used lies and deception
to keep the public blissfully unaware of
the true threats of the Multiverse now
in the main MCU Universe Doctor
Strange's World face stuff and beat
Thanos through using time travel however
in the a3a doctor strange used the dark
cult to dreamwalk and this was so you
could go across the Multiverse to find a
way to defeat Thanos in doing so he
create the incursions and just by
existing in Another Universe this pulled
the realities together in the MCU
spending too much time in another
reality has an almost magnetic effect in
which molecules from each side pulled
together so that they can be whole as we
mentioned in the comics a true cause of
incursions was Dr Doom trying to stop
the death of the Multiverse which then
had a knock-on effect that started to
cause its death however the Multiverse
and the MCU does appear to be all over
the place with the TVA Council of hangs
and dreamwalking being a factor now we
also have a great example in the what if
Episode send it around strange saving
Christine described as a fixed point
this is very similar to a Canon event in
which that variant's version of
Christine had to die this would then
push him on to become doctor strange and
thus it had to be a fixed point in
reality throughout the episode strange
did whatever he could to save her but
this too ended up destroying the
entirety of his Universe now this seems
to be similar how things operating
across the spider-verse with Miguel's
actions causing a world to be destroyed
in the movie we discovered that he was
desperate for a family and as he
traveled to a reality in which a Varian
of him had had one and had then died
however they said massive repercussions
Xena led to him ending that entire world
since then he has tried to stop
non-canon events but in doing this he
just ends up causing them Gwen saves her
father as an affront to his actions
miles is desperate to save his dad and
it's gonna have this knock-on effect
like what we go with doom blood seems to
be the only way to end things in the the
Marvel Universe and we see on the a3a
that the Illuminati had to kill their
strange to avoid any more from happening
we later on meet a Sinister strange
caused one as well and these will likely
be happening across the Multiverse even
though we're unaware of them so yes the
Multiverse is dying and there's probably
millions of incursions happening across
the cosmos that the heroes unable to
comprehend although you might think all
these events are different and they're
basically linked through the same modus
operandi and can show what can end the
Multiverse sounds so bloody clever
saying that now the universe is them I'm
sorry if I've been so pretentious now
the point I'm trying to get across here
is that the universe is themselves
appear to be extremely unstable and even
the slightest change can knock things
off and Destroy them for example you
stop a cannon event like in the case of
Christine or what we get in spite of
Earth then you're gonna cause that
reality to start to fall apart if you
spend too much time in another reality
dreamwalking Then You're Gonna Knock
things off too and everything's gonna
start to head towards Oblivion if you
kill molecule man when you shouldn't and
that's going to set things off as well
and basically doing anything that
shouldn't be in that reality will cause
it to implode the Multiverse is
extremely fragile and frail and everyone
messing around in it what's going to
cause these realities to fall apart you
can start to see why the exiled Kang was
so desperate to stop his variants in
quantumania because they've got the
potential to destroy Reality by meddling
so much though we've never had this
confirmed I think he's likely gonna go
on to become he who remains and through
the TVA they'll stop the offshoot
timelines from destroying it all now
they might use strange as the central
figure in all of this as we learn across
all realities that he has been
dreamwalking this Echoes the comics with
molecule man being the key to all the
incursions except the mcu's Multiverse
destruction is a result of the kangs
either way though once the ball gets
rolling on the incursions there's
absolutely nowhere to stop them as
they're constantly knocking Earths into
other ones and so on and so forth I
think we are slowly seeing everything
fall into place which will lead to it
all playing out in secret Wars and the
comics things culminate with the
timelines being streamlined then we got
a main Universe with some characters
being pulled across from the other
realities this is how miles gotten the
616 and Amy Pascal's announced that a
live-action Miles Morales movie is now
in the works with the appearance of some
live-action characters and across the
spider-verse I'd love to see the miles
from this portal Crossing in the main
MCU and this would be such a cool way to
play on the comics and what's come
before either way we haven't got long
for the Multiverse and I think we'll see
these world ending events happening more
and more and that concludes the video
and hopefully this referral review of
the storyline has helped you get your
heads around what's going on obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on
everything you think will play into the
other films so comment below and let me
know if you want to support the channel
for as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below and
as a thank you get early access to
videos every week we also have our merch
store over at xeroedition.com which
sells lots of nerdy inspired t-shirts
hats and more we just launched a secret
Invasion slash Pulp Fiction inspired
t-shirt so if you want to help us out
get some cool match out of it head over
there and the links in the description
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the ending of across the
spider-verse which will be linked on
screen right now go over everything that
happens in the film explain all the new
characters and yeah definitely head over
there if you're still as hype design
absolutely love the film and yeah I
can't wait to talk about it more coming
the next week make sure you subscribe as
we're going to be dropping lots of
different videos and hopefully you see
over them as I'd love to have you come
back now the way I've been poor you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace